[Musique]
je m'appelle laurent gbagbo j'ai 53 ans
et j'ai fondé marquise hébergeurs en
[Musique]
c'est une activité en deux parties une
activité qui concerne le métier de
tapissier décorateur donc fauteuil
réflexion fauteuil de siège de canapés
et aussi tout ce qui est des corps de
fenêtres voilages rideaux ou stores
bateau par exemple et l'autre partie
c'est une activité de décoration
d'intérieur avec du conseil autour de la
vente de peintures et de papier peint
souvent on est on refait le fauteuil à
partir de sa carcasse à ce qu'on appelle
la carcasse et le fus donc on leurs
sanglots on leur met avec du ressort
là vous pouvez voir derrière moi il doit
y avoir un fauteuil avec du sel en crin
donc ça c'est une garniture dit
traditionnel pique et ensuite avec de
l'or moururent notre projet phare c'est
d'avoir travaillé avec le château de
breteuil depuis 2016 où on a eu quand
même 80 mètres de tissus des
échafaudages pour poser les rideaux ce
qu'on était à 6 mètres sous plafond et
un peu près 20 kg par pardo uniquement
[Musique]
l'aventuré entreprenariale pour moi
c'était la possibilité d'être
indépendante d'être autonome et de prime
abord c'était la possibilité de redonner
une deuxième vie à des objets qui
m'était confiée la possibilité de
recréer des sillages et de les rendre
aux clients en voyant voilà leurs yeux
qui pétillent et d'autre part de faire
aussi un petit peu de création avec par
exemple cette ce petit fauteuil qui a
été trouvés dans les poubelles et qu'on
va remettre en état et qui pourra même
être mis à la vente par la suite et
d'autre part le faire savoir c'est la
possibilité de passer sa compétence
un jeune qui est motivé
[Musique]